I'm Laura Ingram and this is the Ingram
angle on a very busy Friday night so
thanks for joining us hurricane Ian is
not done yet after staggering
Devastation in Southwest Florida the
storm is now moving up the East Coast
we're going to have reports from both
locations in the hour
but we begin tonight with a different
kind of Devastation not the type caused
by mother nature but by corrupt men and
women I'm talking about the economic
Damage Done by those who scammed the
American taxpayers during the pandemic
now this is a story that unfolds in
three parts
first the fraud
just yesterday we learned that nearly
400 Department of Homeland Security
employees took pandemic unemployment Aid
even though they were working
but my friends this is just a teeny tiny
fraction of the massive embrazen covet
theft that has occurred since the
government started dulling out billions
in so-called relief
the official who's in charge of
overseeing the distribution of the
relief has called this the biggest fraud
in a generation
it was the theft of as much as 80
billion dollars or about 10 percent of
the 800 billion dollars that was handed
out in that paycheck Protection Program
now remember that's on top of the 90
billion to 400 billion believed to have
been stolen from the 900 billion coveted
unemployment relief program that's a lot
of money
the second part of this story surrounds
the tidal wave of inflation that all
this unchecked spending and then the
fraud actually caused
the adverse effects of pumping trillions
into the US economy with no safeguards
the FED predicted that the covid
stimulus alone is driving 30 percent of
the current inflationary effects
so that means all those big fat frauds
sitting at their Mexican Resorts during
covid collecting their checks zooming
into meetings ordering their Teslas with
their coveted down payments helped cause
the inflation mess that we're in now
the third part of this story involves
the other opportunists you know those
so-called public servants
they ended up using our national
suffering in some cases to build their
own Brands while they patted their
investment portfolios
I'm talking first about Dr Anthony fauci
who president Trump should never have
put in charge of our coveted response
now looking back on the entire Saga we
see all along it was all about Tony
the cover of in style a place on times
100 most influential documentaries all
the profiles and who could forget the
children's books
but he wants you to believe this Fame
thing was never anything he asked for I
didn't seek it out but I became the
symbol for people which made it an
unrealistic things like you know they're
kind of cute but it's you know bobble
heads and candles and things like that
you have some at home they send them to
me
so what I've learned to do
is not get taken away ego-wise so gross
from the beginning of the whole pandemic
I had my doubts
you're satisfied with all of the
transparency coming out of China today
about the trajectory of the disease and
the origin of the disease in my direct
interaction with Chinese scientists and
Chinese Health officials I can believe
what they're telling me I'm surprised
that you would say that given what we
know
Dr fauci's expertise
no one elected him to anything
now we see that my early suspicions
about fauci is sucking up to China and
his entire Pro lockdown approach proved
to be on target
but it wasn't until May of this year
that we began to really understand the
other ways that fauci was benefiting
that's when our friends at open the
books published this bombshell between
fiscal years 2010 and 2020 more than 350
million in royalties were paid by Third
parties to the agency and NIH scientists
who are credited as co-inventors
well-known scientists receiving payments
During the period included Anthony fauci
who received 23 so-called royalty
payments
now when fauci was asked about this and
specificity he tried to dismiss the
concerns
can you tell me that you have not
received a royalty from any entity that
you ever oversaw the distribution of
money in research grants
them even on their financial statement
if there's nothing to hide
why the secrecy Tony
and how self-satisfied he always comes
across
and tonight we might have further proof
as to why
the same open the books group that
uncovered the NIH royalty payments
published this fauci's net worth
increased by a whopping 65 percent or 5
million dollars during a three-year
period of time that includes 2021 in
other words during the pandemic
so as the elderly were left to die alone
because of the stupid coveted rules he
supported as children were being robbed
of their education because of closures
that he supported and as you were
missing church and weddings and
graduations because of the edicts that
the coveted task force wanted in place
fauci was getting rich
last week Dr fauci said the school
closures were quote worth it
I wonder if he's spoken to folks like
these
children
are many of whom our students are
missing out and losing out an
opportunity because schools are closed
the common sense that has been applied
to setting down this the schools has
been abysmal whose lobbies for the
single parents whose Hobbies
[Applause]
[Music]
well not Anthony fauci
he only had time to lobby for himself
joining me now is Adam and jeffski CEO
and founder of openthebooks.com and
Jason Chaffetz former house oversight
committee chair and Fox News contributor
Adam you say getting these documents has
been a painstaking process so why is the
NIH slow walking
Laura it's been a knock down drag out
dog fight to get the fauci financials
with our legal Partners at Judicial
Watch we actually had to file a federal
lawsuit to get financial disclosures on
fauci from 2015 through 2020. on Tuesday
we finally got the 2021 fauci Financial
disclosures it was the latest they've
ever been produced in some years they
used to come out in February he had
these done in May sometime the latest
they've ever produced them is August on
Tuesday they finally produced them to
our Auditors at openthebooks.com it's
nearly October
Well I this is very curious Jason for
somebody like fauci who claims to be
public servant cares about the what's
good for the people when he was pressed
about this by Rand Paul he got very you
know touchy and dismissive this is very
disturbing
yeah look senator Paul was uh over the
target so to speak and hats off to open
the the books because I got to tell you
this is a person who has worked for the
federal government for decades and yet
he's become a multi-millionaire his wife
happens to be the chief bioethicist uh
for the National Institutes of Health
and yet he had to get a waiver from NIH
to be on the board and work for
McGraw-Hill and also edit the material
that goes into the McGraw-Hill books all
these things they go into the pocketbook
they they just feed the family of the
fauces how do they become literally
north of 10 million dollars in net worth
when you've worked for the federal
government for the last I mean multiple
decades it doesn't it needs exposure and
and people have got to make sure that
this changes yeah there should be no
royalty payments to people who are on
being paid by the taxpayers and you're
getting royalty payments for uh you know
health related activities that you
actually serve to regulate and are
involved in I don't or if that's not
happening tell us what is happening Adam
here's another theft more than a third
of covid-19 recovery funds and 21
developing countries were scooped up by
big corporations now those are the
findings of report released Wednesday by
the financial transparency coalition
Adam explain this for us because I have
to say even I was flabbergasted when I
heard that little factoid
so Laura this is exactly why we need
read the bill legislation and everyone
can come to our website at
openthebooks.com and sign the petition
which would give a 72-hour legislative
time out so our legislators would simply
read the bill so the people the
politicians the pundits so we could see
what's in these massive things think
about the two trillion dollar cares act
that was passed at the height of the
pandemic in March April and nobody knew
what was in there up to 400 million
dollars worth of initial paycheck
Protection Program loans 95 percent of
those turned into grants were paid to
companies owned by the Chinese Communist
party oh my God Marco Rubio out of
Florida got that stopped on the next
covet Aid bill but that's that's why we
need to read the bill Jason you were
there and I know this has happened so
many times that you want to pull your
hair out and I hear this about China you
know getting any benefit with some ever
Nancy Pelosi was still out praising this
today watch
when you talk about the American Rescue
plan it was
there to make sure that we put money in
the pockets of America's Working
Families that gave people more of a
chance to rebound from covet and it was
about fairness
all right Jason and IG report released
this week says that at one point the
American Rescue plan was sending out 200
million dollars in fraudulent or wrong
payments every month
so what do the Republicans have to do
when they get back in charge here
well look there are literally hundreds
of billions of dollars that went out and
waste Fraud and Abuse first of all you
need to starve the Beast stop sending
out this money until you can actually
control what's there the other thing
that I would love for them to do is
there need to be term limits on members
of Congress but there need to be term
limits on the the federal bureaucracy
those people in those higher Echelon
those people also have to turn have to
have term limits because you're not
going to get fresh new voices and and
new looks at things unless you actually
have those as well but they have got to
uncover this is going to take years to
unravel this but they got to send some
people to jail and I really really want
to see the likes of Jim Jordan and and
senator Paul and Ron Johnson go after
Anthony fauci and his wife and figure
out how much money they were making on
decisions that they and they alone were
making hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else